ja und im oktober wäre der kleine tim
aus querfurt drei jahre alt geworden
jetzt ist er tot er wurde misshandelt
und sexuell missbraucht wahrscheinlich
vom freund der eigenen mutter seit
sonntag gesetzt die mutter und auch der
lebensgefährte in untersuchungshaft
polizeieinsatz am birkenweg in der
kleinen stadt querfurt in sachsen-anhalt
hier stirbt am samstag der zweijährige
tim eines qualvollen todes nachbarn und
einwohner der kleinstadt sind
fassungslos
mein freund ist auch die seit jahren
bestimmt gemacht ich habe gucke mal
fenster und da hier sehr wiesengrund
reportern ich habe gehört also es hat
mich fertig gemacht und dann ging mit
einmal vor dem transport rollt die tür
auf und damals für seine lehre aus
zugesandt nein hier ist wirklich jemand
gestorben
und dann kam sondern auch später haben
sie ein leichensack rausgetragen das war
der krieg gänsehaut hoch zehn
kein kind der welt sollte sowas erleben
das hat noch ganze leben vor sich haben
wenn ich nur dran denke dann denke ich
mir die leute muss man einfach umbringen
so hat dieses anhört aber die ums leben
nicht verdient mutter und ihr
lebensgefährte wurden festgenommen
die beiden werden anschließend in
justizvollzugsanstalten eingeliefert
vor ort ergab sich der verdacht dass das
kind eines nicht natürlichen todes
gestorben sein könnte erklärte am
sonntag dennis keynote sprecher der
staatsanwaltschaft halle
die obduktion des toten jungen erhärtet
den grausamen verdacht das kind starb
eines gewaltsamen todes
nach bild informationen soll der
lebensgefährte der mutter stark
betrunken gewesen sein und unter drogen
gestanden haben als polizei und
rettungsdienst die wohnung betrat am
sonntag wird das pärchen vor den
ermittlungsrichter geführt haftbefehl
in gedenken an tim liegen nachbarn und
bekannte des pärchens am wohnhaus am
birkenweg blumen nieder und zünden
kerzen an und zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
josephine barrick vom kinderschutz für
einen neuen lasters guten morgen frau
barbara ja schon wieder ein trauriger
fall von kindesmisshandlung schon wieder
ist ein kind gestorben wie alltäglich
ist diese gewalt gegen kinder in unserer
gesellschaft
ja also man muss natürlich schon sagen
sehr alltäglich ich möchte dass
vielleicht mal kurz erklären anhand der
zahlen der polizeilichen
kriminalstatistik die am 11 mai
veröffentlicht wurde die pks aus der
konnten wir entnehmen dass im jahr 2009
112 kinder in deutschland vorsätzlich
getötet wurden das markt für die
menschen da draußen hat man nie so viel
klingen bei 11,2 millionen kindern in
deutschland rechnen wir das aber mal im
durchschnitt unter dann kommen wir auch
zwei vorsätzlich getötete kinder in der
woche
ja das ist wirklich eine unvorstellbare
zahl zwei kinder vorsätzlich getötet in
einer woche
was fordern sie jetzt muss anders werden
ich darf vielleicht noch kurz eine
anmerkung machen diese kinder die wir
betroffenen kinder von denen ich jetzt
gerade gesprochen habe
die waren jünger als sechs jahre
also gesehen dass dieses thema gewalt an
kinder egal welche gewalt vom
tatsächlich alltäglich ist in
deutschland und hier muss reagiert
werden und zwar umgehend entschuldigung
alles gut was ist da in diesem fall
schiefgelaufen
ich möchte mir nicht anmaßen jetzt
konkret in diesem fall darüber zu
spekulieren was schiefgelaufen helfer
ganz häufig leute dass wir mit extremen
überlastung situationen personellen
überlastung situationen in denen kinder
und jugend in der kinder und jugendhilfe
zu tun haben gerade in den jugendämtern
und auch bei den allgemeinen sozialen
diensten
das ist ein offenes geheimnis dass diese
menschen dort
ich möchte gar nicht unterstellen dass
die nicht wirklich an den familien dran
bleiben wollen sie können es aber häufig
nicht weil sie die personaldecke mich
haben und hier muss man wirklich auch
sagen wir haben wirklich großen
personalbedarf im bereich sozial
pädagogen sozialarbeiter überlegen sie
mal die studierenden auch soziale arbeit
sieben semester dann heißt es ja werben
wie zwei bis drei jahre eben
eingearbeitet aus vertraulicher quelle
weiss ich allerdings nie dabei
entspricht die werden sofort ins kalte
wasser geschmissen und dann erwarten wir
von recht jungen menschen dass die in
solchen prekären familiensituationen
wissen was zu tun ist das ist ja und was
muss ich dann ihrer meinung nach ändern
damit diese zahl diese wirklich
furchtbare zahl zwei kinder in der woche
vorsätzlich getötet sich ändert und
niedriger wird also zu warten natürlich
gewalt über anzeichen eines mann
also man zeichen von fehlender sozialer
unterstützung von fehlender personeller
unterstützung wir brauchen mehr personal
geschult qualifizierte und hochwertig
geschultes personal vielleicht auch
erfahrene menschen in der kinder und
jugendhilfe in den allgemeinen sozialen
diensten zudem brauchen wir endlich mal
auf länder eben auch
kinderschutzbeauftragte wir brauchen wir
kaufen qualitätsstandard schauen wir
mehr als 600 jugendämter im land und
jedes jugendamt macht eigentlich im
grunde was es möchte
es gibt keine einheitliche
vorgehensweisen es gibt keine
einheitlichen qualitätsstandard wenn ich
sie jetzt also qualitätsmanagement in
jedem unternehmen ist eigentlich die
wichtigste instanz nur in der kinder und
jugendhilfe haben wir sie nicht und
vielleicht noch eine anmerkung die
zivilbevölkerung muss natürlich auch
wirklich achtsamer und wachsamer werden
wenn ich höre dass galina an schon
irgendwie alarmiert waren warum hat man
nicht die polizei gerufen warum hat man
nicht immer wieder auf meldungen dann
beginne ich weiß jetzt nicht konkret in
diesem fall gelaufen ist aber ganz
häufig stellen wir eben fest dass eben
auch nachbarn menschen aus dem engsten
oder nächsten weitesten sozialen umfeld
dieser kinder häufig einfach wegschauen
sie haben gerade angesprochen nachbarn
haben irgendwie etwas gemerkt das heißt
worauf sollte man achten was sind
anzeichen und was können wir alle tun um
so etwas in zukunft zu verhindern
wir gehören ja vielleicht auf einen
wagen und wissen sie bei den menschen
ich bei jedem fall nun stellt sich ja
dann irgendwie aus dem gefühl ein
und wenn wir irgendwie der meinung sind
dass kinder nicht gut aufgehoben sind in
der familie wo sie sich befinden dann
haben wir eben auch meldungen zu machen
ein jugendamt wenn die situation extrem
ist ja das ist vielleicht auch geraten
die polizei zu rufen einfach wirklich
den kindern zu helfen in eine stimme zu
geben denn am ende des tages sowie bei
diesem tragischen feiert sind die kinder
dann verloren
sie sterben
josefine barbara vielen dank für ihre
informationen und vielen dank auch für
die klaren worte zu diesem wirklich
wichtigen thema sehr gerne danke